Are we recording? We are!
Let's have some fun on it.
You dream about going up there?
That is a big mistake.
You got to be in slow motion.
No, no, no, it's great.
Good morning, good morning!
So today we're going to Hollywood Studios.
It's our fifth Disney day.
It's our last Disney day.
We're doing Disney today and then shopping tomorrow
and then baseball game on Saturday
and then we leave on Sunday.
Hayden's leg is still hurting him
so we're going to try to get a wheelchair for him again
and see if we can still do Jedi training.
I think we can. We'll see.
I'll talk to them. I'll negotiate.
Okay, well we're driving to Hollywood Studios
and we'll see you then.
Okay, here we are at Hollywood Studios.
It's a really tiny sign.
It's not like the other ones
that we're excited to go through
but we're here! Time to have some fun!
Okay, that was an intense morning.
The Jedi training thing is crazy
where there's a show for Star Wars
and they take 15 kids every hour
and so that's it.
Once 15 kids are full up, they're done
so they get to sign up in advance
so as soon as the gate's open, everybody's rushing, running, running, running.
The line is still here to sign up.
Him and Hayden are somewhere inside, I hope.
And they said he's okay to do it in the wheelchair
so I ran to go get him
his wheelchair
and then got Nina a coffee
and the coffee kind of spilled everywhere
on the way here.
Stress will search the morning
but I think we're going to be okay now.
Just to make sure we get our time
we're going to go check on where they are
and then enjoy the rest of our day. Here we go.
Alright, Hayden is on for 12.35 today.
We've got to come back for Jedi training
so we're going to start by going to
Star Tours.
Here we go.
I got my glasses.
Ready to go in and do some Star Wars.
How come?
It's dead.
Next up, the great movie ride.
Here we are.
What did you think of the Star Wars ride?
Is it fun?
Star Wars?
You don't even care.
You just want to make faces.
Here we are. Great movie ride.
We're getting shaggy.
It's shit.
No, I don't like it.
It hurts.
We get to sit right next to the driver.
The driver is going to be here.
Okay, ready to have some fun?
Here we go.
No more red lights.
Next up, the voyage of the Little Mermaid show.
You dream about
going up there
but that is a big mistake.
Over to Nana.
I don't know.
Is it a lyric?
Yeah.
Taking a selfie with the sign.
One, two.
He's looking angry.
Next up
is the magic of Disney animation.
Next up, we're doing Muppets
3D.
Be quiet.
Ladies and gentlemen, if you can step
as far forward and close together
as you can.
Nina's pretty good.
Let's see what Hayden's doing.
Okay, lunch time.
A little bit healthier.
We still got pizza.
I have a pizza.
But we have some salads.
I have a little cup.
Nina has a big cup.
And we're going to do this.
And then we're going to do, ready?
Jedi training.
How's the salad?
Who loves Nina the most?
Me. I do.
I love her more.
I'm going to put your hand down because I love her more.
I'm putting your hand down because I love her more.
This is what we do at lunch.
Shark pirate.
There she goes. We got to keep up.
Hayden just got his padawan outfit.
Three.
Boom.
Welcome to the Jedi
training academy.
In time, you will call
me master.
Are you afraid of the dark side?
Tell them you're not afraid.
I'm scared.
So they can hear you.
And now you play.
Activate.
Now go for the red light saber.
Go for the other side.
And go for the leg.
Good. Same leg.
Under leg.
Now the head.
Activate.
Isn't that fun?
If you want to freak with him.
Good job.
Hello.
It's Nina.
You want to show us how you're doing it again?
Show us from this angle.
Boom. To the head.
Boom. Duck.
Attack.
Good job mister.
High five.
Alright. Padawan Hayden has completed
his Jedi training.
And now we are at the Indiana Jones
spectacular show.
Do you want to send this one?
Say hi first.
Are we excited to watch Indiana Jones?
Let me just show you what I
got. What do you have?
This. Oh, that's a certificate for you.
You're a padawan. Yeah.
Perfect.
Oh, and I got a secret button.
What's a secret button?
It says Jedi Hayden on it.
And it has a secret light saber.
Nice.
Is this from Indiana Jones? Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, sunscreen. I thought I was just
getting a massage. Just putting sunscreen on.
Like, ooh, I'm feeling the Indiana Jones
massage.
I hope it's great. But, the
subsequent scene today, this is all
a performing event. It's very real.
And the cat is a poo.
Alright,
up next is the Frozen
sing along celebration.
Nina's ready to sing. Something Frozen?
Oh, I don't sing.
Let it go. Let it go.
Let it go.
Alright, let's hope it's fun.
The world is howling
like this swirling storm
inside.
Should keep it
heaven knows I
will try.
Don't let them in. Don't
let them see. Be the
good girl. Always have
to be. Conceal, don't
feel. Don't let them
know.
Well, now
let it go.
Let it go.
Can't hold me back anymore.
Turn away and slam
the door.
Okay, who has more snow on
them? Who has more snow
on them? I've got a lot of
snow. Nina has her sunglasses
on inside.
Hayden has a lot of snow.
Look at your head. You've got plenty of snow
on you.
I have more? Maybe I have more.
Alright. Okay, we're at
our second last show of the day.
The extreme stunt
show. Spectacular
with cars and motorcycles.
You excited?
Yeah.
Nina's excited. She might get scared.
Oh no, it started to rain.
So they're going to be doing crazy stunts along this
path.
But it's raining. See?
It's raining. So hopefully
they don't cancel it. What are we going to do when we
get out? It's raining.
It's windy. It's windy and
it's raining. Hayden has his poncho though, right?
But Nina and I don't have our umbrella.
Okay, well the
show is half an hour so hopefully they don't cancel it.
Fingers crossed. Fingers crossed.
Nina really likes it.
We're coming soon.
Isn't that scary?
That was scary.
That was crazy. Okay, it's time for
our last Disney World ride
for the year.
Toy Story. You excited?
That's our last ride of the year. You excited?
No.
No, it's over. Let's have some fun
on it. We got to shoot things
but we also have to wear glasses.
I've been here once.
But you haven't been here.
And Nina's chucking her hair in the camera.
I've been wearing my hat
the whole day. It still looks good.
Yeah, hello.
We're on our ride. We're rocking
the glasses. Nina on my right
with the green cannon.
Hayden on my left with the yellow
cannon. Show them how you fire it.
Yeah.
And I am just a cannon man.
Tears.
This is Nina. She's a sharp shooter.
Start shooting things.
Whoa.
You guys are crazy.
Hayden's very squishy.
Whoa.
Okay, that was official.
Here we go.
Backwards.
Ow, my knee.
Get the pigs.
It's almost over.
Go, go, go.
Oh.
You guys did well.
How's your arm feeling?
Tired?
Go, Hayden, go.
Attack, attack.
How's your arm, Hayden?
Are you tired?
Wow.
Wow, Nina, 89,000.
Hayden, 28,000.
He almost had the same accuracy as you though, babe.
28% accuracy.
33%.
Was that fun? Yeah.
That's right? Yeah.
Nina had fun? Yeah.
How's your arm?
Give us a flex.
Do your arms start too?
Look at the muscle.
Yeah.
My arms are fine. I don't know what they're complaining about.
These guys are weaklings.
That's it.
That's the end of our Disney trip.
What do you want to say?
Bye, bye, Disney World.
Was it fun?
Goodbye, Disney World.
Yeah, it was fun.
Okay, we'll see you next year.
Bye.
Thanks for watching.